bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour
l'actualité sur tv fil 78 nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'action directe si vous
venez de nous rejoindre à 18 heures
voici quelques-uns des titres que nous
allons développer en ce lundi 7 octobre
à la semaine du handicap à montigny le
bretonneux à 10 ans comme chaque année
des animations sont prévues invités de
cette édition à marie noëlle tard au
maire adjointe en charge de l'action
sociale de la ville avec qu'il nous
verrons si le regard des valides a bel
et bien changé les principales capitales
mondiales étaient au rendez-vous et des
nuits blanches à un rendez vous
artistique gratuit qui fait des émules
et l'encours s'est lancé dans le bal
retour sur l'événement avec la
performance notamment d'un artiste
manutention et puis la radio yvelinois
sensation dévoile sa grille pour cette
saison elle vient de lancer ce week-end
son nouveau au rendez-vous l'hebdo
politique on passe à présent à l'image
du jour c'est l'inauguration ce matin à
trappes de la plate forme de la mobilité
bouger vers l'emploi en présence du
ministre délégué à l'économie sociale et
solidaire benoît hamon le but de cet
organisme d'état facilité ou aider à
organiser la mobilité des demandeurs
d'emploi qui rencontrent des difficultés
dans leurs déplacements professionnels
en partenariat avec pôle emploi les
missions locales et l'association
voiture enhco 300000 euros de budget ont
été alloués à cette plateforme
environ un millier de personnes par an
vont être pris en charge les précisions
par exemple le cas le plus concret c'est
demain jauger trouver un travail
j'ai les compétences pour ce travail je
dois me rendre dans une zone d'activité
à 3 heures du matin parce que je dois
prendre mon poste à ce moment là mais
j'ai prouvé ya pas de transports en
commun j'ai pas de voiture je n'ai pas
le permis de conduire comment je fais
ben voilà voiture et colas à ce moment
là bas va vous permettre qu'on va
rentrer dans un tout un process le
premier princesse ça va être de vous
accompagner à l'emploi pour que vous
puissiez pérenniser et gardez votre
situation
et puis dans un second temps on va
former à une mobilité donc ça peut être
formé par exemple à l'utilisation d'un
scooter et pouvoir louer le scooter
derrière alors et après ils imaginaient
un microcrédit pour qu'ils puissent
acheter son scooter donc vraiment
l'ambition c'est de traiter chaque eu
des moments de parcours vers une
mobilité autonome et un projet de
transport micro collectif pour certaines
zones d'activités mal desservies dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin serait
aussi à l'étude
le manque de transports un frein à
l'emploi est justement à quelle distance
se trouve votre entreprise de votre
domicile c'est notre question du jour
la distance en entend de transport
c'était une demi heure le matin trois
quarts d'heure ressort de nick mans la
voiture et ça s'est passé comment très
aléatoire surtout pour y avait de la
neige
oh je sais pas je suis à peu près un
quart d'heure en marchant vite à
elancourt donc c'était à peu près trois
quarts d'heure le bus est mal desservi
pour aller là-bas donc
c'était en fait le gros du trajet c'est
l attente du bus était pas c'était pas
le trajet dure 20 minutes à pied les
trois kilomètres passés le même c'est là
il n'y a pas de distance je travaille à
la maison je n'aurais minutes alors le
cran environ 800 mètres la voiture et
parfois de vélo et 10 ans pour la
semaine du handicap sur montigny le
bretonneux lancée en 2004 par le centre
d'action communal d'hommes centre
communal d'action sociale et d'autres
services de la mairie elle permet durant
quelques jours de sensibiliser adultes
et enfants invités de cette édition
marie noëlle tarot bonsoir nous soit
revenu sur ce plateau vous êtes maire
adjointe en charge de l'action sociale à
montigny le bretonneux dix ans d'action
et que lorsque vous évoquez le bilan
vous nous dit aujourd'hui que le regard
a changé c'est le constat que vous
faites c'est c'est le constat que nous
faisons quand même ce n'est pas à 100%
bien entendu mais c'est vrai que le
regard a changé et surtout le fait que
le travail que nous avons essayé de
développer c'était un travail vis-à-vis
des enfants et donc nous sommes partis
du principe que si nous informions ce
qu'était le handicap si nous faisions
participer les enfants est bien petit à
petit au fur et à mesure de leur
évolution lorsqu'ils deviendront
adolescents et lorsqu'ils seront adultes
eh bien peut-être qu'ils n'auront plus
disons tous ceux qui faisaient le fera à
la connaissance du handicap et le fait
de se dire que
quelqu'un a dit un jour qu'on était tous
des handicapés en puissance
effectivement pourquoi pas mais que
c'est pas parce qu'on est handicapé
qu'on ne peut pas faire des choses qu'on
ne peut pas être elle regarde bien mangé
ça veut dire que son nom son considère
les personnes en situation de handicap
d'égal à égal tout simplement dans les
échanges dans les regards ils monteront
descendance qu'est-ce qui change
concrètement ce qui change je pense
c'est que effectivement on est tous
différents alors ça c'est une réalité
le handicap c'est à un moment donné une
incapacité de faire quelque chose mais
ça ne nous empêche pas de faire d'autres
choses
donc effectivement être handicapé c'est
peut-être être en fauteuil et ça veut
dire qu'effectivement je ne peux pas
courir mais je dois pouvoir me déplacer
dans la ville
je dois pouvoir garer ma voiture je dois
pouvoir
si je suis un enfant à aller à l'école
participé à des activités sportives
culturelles
il ne faut pas que le handicap soit un
frein à ce que je peux développer et
pouvoir utiliser toutes mes capacités
c'est vraiment ça l'objectif de cette
semaine c'est de se dire que être
handicapé c'est vrai c'est une
difficulté mais il faut que l'on puisse
et bien profiter de ce qui peut être
autour de nous de faire des rencontres
des échanges on est aussi c'est ce que
je dis on essaye de dire que la semaine
du handicap c'est aussi le rire le
sourire la rencontre et l'échangé c'est
très festif ya de nombreuses animations
sont prévues jusqu'au 13 octobre les
animations qui ont débuté depuis
dimanche depuis hier par rallye nous y
étions à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
derniers préparatifs avant le grand
départ
grâce au module évasion reginaldo
s'apprête à se balader en pleine nature
dans son propre fauteuil électrique sans
permet de découvrir la nature est
actuellement deux évasions donc
partout à tous quatre modules nicolino
la boue tous partout partout cette
cinquième édition du rallye découverte à
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines permet aux personnes à mobilité
réduite de s'essayer à de nouvelles
activités
ils sont un peu considérés comme des
personnes à part entière alors que
souvent on les regarde de travers là ils
sont accueillis donc c'est vraiment une
chance extraordinaire
et ils sont comme tout le monde et lors
de cette journée valides et handicapés
se mélangent quand on se rencontre et
qu'on se connaît il ya des chances que
le contact face et qu'on se regarde
différemment c'est pour ça qu'on a envie
de montrer qu'on est là pour tous pour
la famille pour les jeunes les personnes
âgées les ce que l'on me bitty réduite
ceux qui sont valides et tous ensemble
eh bien on s'active pour promouvoir
la diversité la mule et multi talents et
c'est stéphane accompagnée de sa fille
victoire a laissé son fauteuil roulant
pour un siège tout terrain est là avec
ce fauteuil tout terrain on peut se
promener dans l'herbe dans la rive
gauche un peu partout dans la boue gas
exactement et puis ça permet d'essayer
du matériel qu'on peut pas avoir
personnellement et ça permet de se
promener en toute liberté ses fers pour
la dixième semaine du handicap ces
activités sont proposées jusqu'à
vendredi
au programme tir à l'arc qu'elle échoue
encore grimpe à lumbres des personnes à
part entière les personnes en situation
de handicap sont des personnes à part
entière c'est ce qu'on vient d'entendre
ces témoignages au cours de ce reportage
nous évoquons cette semaine du handicap
à montigny le bretonneux avec la maire
adjointe de la commune on vient de voir
le rallye c'est la cinquième édition
mais c'est la première fois que montigny
s'y associent voilà oui c'est vrai que
l'office du tourisme qui est un peu à
l'origine de cette journée les deux
cette semaine puisque ça continue à
dérouler tout au long de la semaine
comme nous d'ailleurs
et bien effectivement nous a demandé de
venir et nous étions hier matin très
heureux de pouvoir participer et de
lancer lisons 7
cette journée par semaine du handicap
qui s'associe donc avec cette initiative
qui se poursuit à la base de loisirs
vous venez de mentionner comment est né
dans l'idée des élus à
montigny-le-bretonneux l' envie de
participer à cette semaine du handicap
qui est une semaine nationale alors la
semaine du handicap pour nous ça a été
quelque chose qui s'est développée la
première fois sur une idée de la ville
c'est la ville qui a eu cette idée parce
que nous avions déjà lancé une
commission communale d'accessibilité et
nous entendions un petit peu parce que
nous avons souhaité que les personnes
qui participent à cette commission soit
des personnes en situation et non pas
des représentants parce que ça aussi
c'est important parce que qui peut mieux
qu'une personne en situation de handicap
expliquer ses besoins comment elle va
pouvoir se déplacer comment elle va
pouvoir aller regarder une pièce de
théâtre etc
donc il nous est venue cette idée de
dire dans le fond est bien essayons de
mettre un petit peu en avant et c'est
comme ça qu'on a on est parti sur l'idée
de changer le regard sur le handicap et
donc c'est comme ça que nous avons
commencé au départ c'était assez modeste
on
une semaine mais sur laquelle bon
c'était un petit peu je vais pas dire
difficile mais nous avons pu commencer
et puis maintenant c'est vrai que quand
je vois le programme de la semaine je me
dis c'est extraordinaire on a des
rencontres tous les ans qui sont des
rencontres formidables avec des
personnes extraordinaires et je trouve
que c'est très valorisant même pour nous
enfin on est vraiment très heureux de
participer enfin évoqué ce programme
justement si vous souhaitez le consulter
dans son intégralité rendez vous sur le
site internet de la ville de montigny le
bretonneux juste auparavant
comment intervient la ville en matière
de handicap quelle est la politique de
la ville est ce que vous développez des
actions tout au long de l'année je sais
qu'il en a plusieurs
notamment le journal municipal qui a
enregistré sur cd ça c'est pour les
haies les personnes qui ne peuvent pas
lire
quels sont les autres initiatives qui
sont alors donc effectivement on
travaille à la fois avec les services de
la ville bien entendu et puis avec des
bénévoles parce que le montigny audio
comme nous le rappelons est bien ce sont
des bénévoles et c'est en partenariat
avec l'association valentin haüy nous
avons aussi bien sûr ça fait plusieurs
années et même bien avant la semaine du
handicap nous avons des pistes des
classes adaptées pour les enfants en
situation de handicap
nous avons développé une salle de
psychomotricité dans le cadre de la
petite enfance nous accueillons aussi
des enfants des petits en situation de
handicap bien entendu il faut toujours
être attentif et ne pas aller au delà de
la capacité d'intégration à la fois pour
le bien-être que ce soit du petit enfant
de l'enfant que de ceux qui sont autour
donc c'est tout un travail de
partenariat d' écoute avec les familles
avec les accueillants que ce soit les
éducateurs que ce soit les éducateurs
sportifs
donc nous essayons vraiment de mettre en
place un accompagnement qui va permettre
à l'enfant à la fois ci c'est un enfant
bien entendu de se développer et de
participer mais aussi d'être accueillie
et que tout se passe bien si ça
l'objectif d'ici à 2015 il y avait une
loi sur l'accessibilité des bâtiments
publics la ministre marie arlette
carlotti a reconnu elle-même que ce
serait difficile et qu'en 2015 toutes
les communes elles n'auront pas réussi à
rendre leurs bâtiments publics
accessibles pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et je précise de
tous les handicaps
c'est ce qui rend la tâche encore plus
difficile vous en êtes où sur montigny
le bretonneux
alors j'ai envie de dire que sur ce que
l'on peut appeler l'accessibilité
motrices nous avons quand même
nous sommes plutôt bien placé puisque de
toute façon nous avons la chance d'être
dans une ville nouvelle
enfin nouvelle maintenant nous ne sommes
plus vils nouvelle mais c'est une ville
qui s'est construit déjà avec cette
réflexion sont pas moins de contraintes
que sur paris ou sur d'autres villes
très ancienne et très très pittoresque
mais qui sont difficilement accessibles
nous travaillons aussi sur du personnel
qui apprend la langue des signes donc
c'est vrai que nous sommes aussi en
train de réfléchir à des moyens plus
modernes sur le fait de l'apprentissage
et du contact
nous avons donc effectivement pu
développer grâce à l'association du
théâtre au clair de la lune qui est une
un théâtre qui a été mis en place pour
des personnes handicapées
nous avons les souffleurs d'image qui
peuvent venir lors des spectacles nous
avons permis à ce que la gratuité d'une
personne handicapée pour qu'elles sont
accompagnant puisse il n'ya pas moi
quand je vais au théâtre j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir un accompagnons donc il n'y a
pas de raison que la compagnie soit
obligé de payer donc la glande budget
pour tout ça ah oui c'est chaque année
la bulle s'est alors rien vu dèja il ya
deux actions il ya l'action du ccas
bien entendu et puis il ya l'action
communale est donc là c'est dans le
budget municipal et ce sont vraiment des
actions que nous développons au niveau
du conseil municipal dans quel endroit
de destituer budget consacrée au
handicap
alors là vous me posez ce sera
l'occasion pour la 11e édition
on va revenir à la semaine du handicap
pour terminer cet entretien un programme
toujours chargé du en fauteuil du basket
fauteuil pour le sport il ya aussi des
ateliers de sensibilisation sur les
accueils de loisirs des concerts
percussions aussi tout au long de la
semaine quel est le moment fort alors le
moment au fort ben oui je veux dire que
c'est toute la semaine et sierra leone 0
il ya plusieurs quand même moment fort
il ya le mardi midi lorsque nous faisons
la course inter entreprises avec
l'association spécial olympics nous
avons je crois déjà presque une
soixantaine d'équipés cette année qui se
sont qui se sont engagés et reviendront
je vous interromps dans l'acte de demain
soir dans le 7-8 seule facture rendez
vous demain 18h pour découvrir le résumé
de cette journée
voila voila intime et donc le mardi soir
nous avons teranga kate une un groupe de
percussions et de rythmes africains qui
intègre des personnes en déficience
intellectuelle
nous avons alors jeudi soir c'est la
soirée on va dire un petit peu
anniversaire comme que nous avons appelé
dix ans déjà
parce que c'est vrai que d'un seul coup
quand on se retourne ça fait déjà 10 ans
que nous travaillons sur sur cette
thématique est donc jeudi soir nous
avons la présence de mathieu gary qui
lui est un handicap invisible et qui
chante qui est un chanteur compositeur
interprète
nous avons aussi laurent savard qui est
un humoriste qui a un petit garçon
autiste et qui nous explique comment il
vit et comment on accueille son enfant
de temps en temps avec quelquefois un
humour un peu grinçant mais le rire est
toujours présent et puis nous aurons
aussi la présentation du film de
philippe ribière wild one qui explique
tout son parcours depuis très rapidement
sa naissance jusqu'à ce formidable
grimpeur et quand on le voit grimper ou
on oublie cet homme de défi
effectivement mise en oeuvre plusieurs
fois champion surtout il concerne l
escalade g sur toile toutes les
montagnes du monde sur les plus hauts
sommets je m'en sers pression' répit le
dimanche ans et la clôture voilà
dimanche et la clôture avec le hand
ighram bien entendu où philippe bien sûr
sera là il y aura aussi le défi goût du
triathlon de l'espérance avec médias
média handicap et puis des associations
qui viennent pour présenter et pour
renseigner et éventuellement les
personnes qui le souhaitent une
présentation chorégraphique avec la paye
donc et puis du handbike aussi et puis
et puis on sur le site internet de la
ville voilà pour avoir le programme
complet merci à vous merci d'être passé
sur ce plateau à 10 ans de la semaine du
handicap jusqu'au 13 octobre à montigny
le bretonneux
le président de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines qui
vient de tenir sa conférence de presse
de rentrée malgré un déficit annoncé de
5 millions d'euros il évoque 2014 comme
une année de transition de construction
entre le projet paris-saclay l'ouverture
d'un institut d'études politiques
également et puis autre nouveauté un fab
lab
il s'agit de favoriser le travail entre
les universitaires et les entreprises
locales
les explications donc il s'agit d'avoir
un espace ouvert de rencontre ouvert
donc sur l'environnement c'est à dire ça
peut être le citoyen ça peut être ça
peut être ça doit être les pme tpe voire
volume des grands groupes qui ont pas
tout à fait la même problématique qui
viennent sur le sur l'espace de
assaillent pour rencontrer dans les
anciens chercheurs rencontre les
étudiants pour essayer de faire émerger
des projets ont pour faire avancer des
projets suivants l'ain c'est d'offrir
donc les compétences de mettre à
disposition quelque part les compétences
des enseignants des chercheurs mais
également de mettre à disposition toutes
les plateformes technologiques qu'on
peut avoir sur ce campus en chimie et en
physique également toutes les ressources
qu'on a en termes numérique documentaire
culture la nuit blanche s'était aussi à
saint quentin en yvelines à elancourt un
artiste devenue a fait parler de lui son
nom de scène manutention sont à réparer
les objets de la rue avec des matériaux
en bois à rouge
olivier maniscalco patrick jacques de
dixmude
il ne fait pas partie du personnel
technique de la ville d'elancourt et
pourtant il répare le mobilier urbain de
la ville lui c'est manutention le
soigneur de ruffier emmanuel boillon de
son vrai nom est un artiste qui grâce
aux matériaux abandonnés qu'ils
récupèrent combler les manques une vitre
de cabines téléphoniques briser un banc
public sans dossier ou une rampe
d'escalier détériorer manu arpentent les
rues et guérit la ville avec ses
installations éphémères en bois rouge
les interventions restent vraiment
intégré sur un hobby et nos cris a pas
versé dans mobinil même vis est dedans
je m'attaque en fait sauter de la
ficelle par emboîtement en fait c'est
possible de l'enlever solutionner
endroits difficiles jeu
j'ai difficile
moi ma muse et aussi avec les structures
et ce cadre elle aussi un souci de
composition dans les structures que je
crée
comment attirer l'oeil en fait et donc
cassé avec le rythme d'un mobile
résidents permanents jusqu'au mois de
juillet prochain saint quentin maniora
l'occasion d'apporter un peu de couleur
sur le territoire yvelinois une
exposition une image lui est également
consacrée à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt du 9 octobre au 24 novembre
michel fau metteur en scène interprète
de demain il fera jour est à versailles
afin de superviser les dernières
répétitions au théâtre montansier dans
cette pièce de henry de montherlant il
est question d'un père qui laisse entrer
son fils dans la résistance non pas par
conviction mais par intérêt personnel et
dont l'un des principaux rôles on
retrouve léa drucker ce sera à découvrir
demain 8 octobre à 20h30 on écoute en
attendant michel fau c'était cet après
midi montherlant donne un regard pas du
tout manichéen sûr sur cette période il
observe un couple de bourgeois dans le
l'homme a été plus ou moins
paco labeaume et il a
il a défendu un allemands pendant la
guerre extra c'est léa drucker qui joue
le rôle de la de la mer qui est une
femme apparemment assez assez futile
assez inconsciente et puis qui va se
révéler après un être humain comme tous
les autres et puis on a un fils qui
jouait pas l'eau avec mobilians et qui
en fait qui nous annonce qui veut entrer
dans la résistance
donc au début le peuvent pas la mère
elle veut parce qu'elle est le gat son
enfant et et puis après ça ce sens
inverse c'est à dire la mère a peur donc
elle veut plus qu'il entre en résistance
et le père lui espère se racheter une
voilà une netteté et qui sont fusent
entre dans la résistance
la 20e édition de la fête des vendanges
à elancourt 160 pieds de vignes sont
plantées on cultive aussi bien du raisin
blanc que du raisin noir quelle sera la
qualité de la cuvée de cette année
question posée à jean flattot le
président des amis du passé d'elancourt
non vous n'êtes pas à la campagne ni
dans le bordelais ou en bourgogne mais
dans le vieux village d'el on court
derrière la ferme du mousseau là où sont
plantés 160 pieds de vigne du raisin
noir et du raisin blanc ici on avait
dégoupillé de réserve de raisin blanc
est donc un hybride qui est noté ici la
cdu chez villard 52 76 tous les ans
l'association des amis du passé
d'elancourt s'active avec les enfants à
perpétrer la tradition des vendanges
d'abord la taille de la vigne les
premiers pieds ont été plantés il ya 22
ans soit encore sous le coup de la g une
année moyenne si ce n'est sur le
mûrissement voit que malgré la mairie ce
mot qui n'est pas complet et bien que et
à l'arrivée on pourrait faire même déjà
dirait du bon champagne on a du raisin
noir peut-être qui est pas mûri
complètement mais et quand on goûte le
jus de raisin mais c'est inattendu c'est
à dire il est malgré tout sucre et de y
avoir un peu degré d'alcool après la
taille de la vigne opération foulage à
l'ancienne là ce sont les petits pieds
d'enfants qui officie pour écraser des
grains de raisin et il n'y a pas d'âge
l'impression est mitigée en fait ben je
suis en train d'être années le rêve est
relayée vie berges les hyper froid bas
pour fabriquer du jus de raisin
il vint c'est froid et puis c'est un peu
dégoûtant rassure-toi emma tout est
prévu un pédiluve est installé pour se
nettoyer les pieds une pause dégustation
le raisin sera ensuite grappes et puis
presser cette année les vendanges
devraient permettre de produire une
vingtaine de litres de jus de raisin une
trentaine de litres de vin blanc et 120
litres de rosé à consommer bien entendu
avec modération le dessus de pasteurisés
jus de raisin on en a fait une douzaine
et puis là on allait de nous
c'est dans une cave en terre battue et
en pierre de molière que le précieux
liquide et conserver cette année les
vendanges ils encourent fêter leurs 20
ans sport le grand prix des chèques de
paris s'est achevée ce week end
rappelons que l'événement piloté par la
fédération internationale était
organisée à la commanderie des templiers
à elancourt là où se trouve le siège de
la fédération française de la discipline
les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux étaient
présents c'est l'italien fabiano caruana
qui l'emportent
deux français étaient engagés etienne
bacrot qui termine à un demi point
seulement du leader à la troisième place
ex-aequo avec le numéro 5 mondial
laurent frayssinet lui en bas de tableau
il faisait figure d'outsider dans cette
compétition mais pour les spécialistes
il a su rivaliser avec les meilleurs
sports toujours et puis du basket avec
ce derby entre trappe et le chesnay
versailles c'est de la nationale 3 ce
sont les trappistes qu'ils l'emportent
et qui accède ainsi à la deuxième place
de leur poule et derrière poissy
toujours invaincus en trois matches
anthony rech patrick jacques de dixmude
comme un signe pour son premier derby
trappistes sur le banc versailles et
romain du bos affronte son ancien
formateur mostafa el hafidi c'est un
match particulier ça fait dix ans je
crois qu'on a pas vu un derby traversa
et donc forcément ça une saveur
particulière moi j'étais
j'étais gamin quand j'ai vu derniers
matches des trades versailles donc c'est
un peu particulier même pour moi on va
démarrer ce match là plein pot comme on
sait le faire on va jouer notre chance
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout ils
tenteront de contrecarrer la marche en
avant saint-quentinoise notre équipe est
meilleure de semaine en semaine c'est
une équipe tout jeune en âge mais
également en cohésion puisqu'ils se
connaissent depuis un mois 1 est donc
cette cohésion est en train de se
construire
largement dominé dans les airs les
versaillais met comme prévu beaucoup de
riz dès les premières minutes de jeu
pour surprendre la défense
saint-quentinoise et avec 15 fautes
d'équipé au cours de la première période
l'un discipline trappistes coûte cher
après avoir eu six points de retard les
versailles et bascule logiquement en
tête à la pause 35 33 passes au jeu très
offensif des visiteurs les trappistes
répondent par une belle adresse
extérieure et un festival de deuil de
diallo mameri en fin de match les jeunes
joueurs saint quentinois prouve leur
maîtrise devant l'expérience
versaillaise les trappistes pour la loi
au rebond est toujours aussi adroit au
shoot il creuse l'écart pour finalement
s'imposer 80-69 la marche était un peu
haut pour le lcd face à une équipe
taillée pour la nationale 2 on sait que
c'est un derby il fallait assurer
koukougnon bon en fait ce qu'il fallait
on a on appliquer les consignes du coach
et puis ça a payé
pour terminer ce journal coup d'oeil sur
la programmation de nos confrères de
radio sensations à la proche des
municipales et des européennes nicolas
kirillovitch se reçoit chaque semaine
des maires des communes de
l'agglomération mais aussi des militants
l'occasion également de revenir sur les
nouveautés de la rentrée de radio
sensations violaine 13 anthony rech
l'hebdo politique
nico bien qu'ils aient envie
un tout nouveau rendez vous sur
l'antenne de radio sensations
nicolas qui rit le vide se reçoit de
militants et élus pour parler politique
chaque dimanche à partir de 18 heures ce
jour là il reçoit le maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous
on va recevoir les maires de tous de
toute la communauté d'agglo de 50 ans
guyancourt magny les hameaux
voilà pour connaître les enjeux de
chaque ville et puis connaître leur
point de vue aussi sur l'actu national
on fait toujours un petit ricoché sur la
nationale c'est un fardeau
c'est le sauveur du rapide pour
l'instant l'hebdo politique est
programmé jusqu'à mars 2014 mais nicolas
n'exclut pas de prolonger l'expérience
il ya des régionales en 2015 et puis
après il ya les y aura forcément les
présidentielles 2010 est donc ouais
pourquoi pas continuer moi c'est ce
qu'ont choisi municipale toujours le
gluant courtois ladislas secours âgé de
25 ans sera la tête de liste ump des
allures haut pour les prochaines
élections de mars prochain sur radio
sensations c'est de la musique tous les
jours et des informations locales dès
6h30 chaque matin à partir de 20h des
émissions thématiques sont proposées et
dès cette semaine il y à du nouveau
notamment le toque à partir de 20 heures
donc une émission de débat
avec un certain nombre de jeunes qui
seront là pour traiter des sujets de
société d'actualité et on a quelques
ovnis aussi on a une émission de country
qui fonctionne très très bien le
dimanche à partir de 21h et une émission
de jazz à partir de 23 heures
tout cela est à écouter sur le 98 points
4 sans langue de bois c'est la fin de ce
journal je vous retrouve demain 18h en
direct excellent de soirée sur tf1